This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit, and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec.
I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
On the new podcast, Solita, we share the message. reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Your bookshelf and your for you page are equally important to your personality. Welcome home.
Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of women's health and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause.
Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. You guys know the drill. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I have a mini bite-sized episode for you all. This is part of our broader debunking psychology series we've been doing recently where
we take popular psychology terms, popular psychology phrases that have become widely used in society, sometimes misused, and we break down exactly what they mean and the real evidence-based science and history that most people just don't know. We've covered personality tests. We've done Stockholm Syndrome, trauma buns, narcissism, and today we turn our attention to one of the biggest of them all, which is the Oedipus Complex. You have probably heard about the Oedipus Complex in TV shows, comedy routines, newspaper headlines, gossip magazines, everyday conversations, and you may know it means something
raunchy. You may have an idea that it means something to do with maybe sex, maybe some other, are rated themes, but today I really just want to break it down entirely for you. A quick disclaimer, this episode talks about sex and it talks about sexual attraction in a kind of, in a strange and not always pleasant to discuss context. I'm going to say it that way. This is purely for educational purposes. but if you are sensitive to topics around sex and around attraction and children,
it may be best to skip this episode. As I said, all educational, but sometimes a little bit sensitive. So let's get into it. So to begin with, let's just cover the basics. What is the Oedipus Complex? What does it mean? How did it originate? So, the Oedipus Complex describes a conflict that Sigmund Freud believed emerged during early childhood.
In its most familiar form, the Oedipus Complex is basically this idea that a young boy develops an unconscious sexual or romantic desire for his mother. And as a result of that, begins to view his father, who in this kind of form already occupies the position beside her, as a rival. It's important to stress the word unconscious here. So Freud, the person who first began speaking about this idea and gave it its name, he wasn't claiming that four-year-olds consciously sit there and think about entering a sexual relationship with their mothers. Instead, he kind of believed these wishes existed beneath our conscious awareness and appeared indirectly. So appeared through things like intense affection for one's mother, possessiveness, jealousy, fantasy, and competition with the father.
You know, when a child becomes irritated or annoyed because the dad is kissing the mom, like Freud interpreted that as symbolic. Or when a child, so specifically a boy child in this scenario, when he's saying, you know, I want to marry mommy when I grow up. Again, Freud saw that as indicative of the Oedipus complex. unconscious desire for the mother and an unconscious competition with the father. Because of these unconscious desires, the child experiences a weird kind of strange situation where they both rely on their mother but also love her in a strange way.
And then they also rely on their father but feel competition and fear for him in the same way. They believe, well, according to Freud, he believed that when a young boy begins to see their mother this way, they believe that if their father were to find out about it, they would hurt them or harm them. And so they also feel all these very complex relationships towards what are actually their caregivers and the people who need to take care of them. So this combination of love and hostility and fear creates the psychological conflict that is at the center of the complex. in Freud's mind there was this kind of four-way pathway going on where a child or a boy loves their mother also loves their father desires their mother is jealous of the father and is fearful of the father so this is the basic premise let's talk about where Freud got this idea from because if we're being honest it's a pretty weird idea like every everything I say
about this part of me is like oh I need to just double clarify that this is not my belief this is a belief of long, long ago that I think in the modern day we kind of just look at and say is very creepy and unnecessary. However, it has a historical role and it is a theory that exists, so where did it come from? So the Oedipus Complex came about through a combination of Freud's clinical work with adult patients, his interpretations of their dreams and their symptoms. he read a lot into literature and mythology. And he also based this theory on his own self-analysis.
So based on how he fell about his mother and how he felt about his father. Very important to clarify. This theory did not come from any kind of official study, experiment, or any kind of structured scientific research. It is what we would call a singular anecdotal. theory coming from the mind of one person. So I said that he did a lot of self-analysis about this. Well, it was actually the death of his father in 1896 that really triggered Freud to start thinking about this and he really began reflecting upon his own childhood and his attachment to his mother and his feelings towards his father. Essentially, this man had a lot of really deep
wounds to do with his parents. And he obviously had a lot of really weird feelings about his parents, as is indicated by his creation of this Oedipus complex idea. And unlike the normal person who would have these experiences and say, that's a bit weird, that's probably something for me to deal with. He said, well, I think everybody else must feel this way as well. And I think this must be a thing that every single young boy goes through. This is a theory of human development that we haven't figured out yet. And so I'm talking about it for the first time. Now, the name Edipus and the story of Edipus that gave this complex, its name, is a lot older than Freud's theory. As I said, Freud, you know, we see him as this like researcher
scientist. He kind of also just really liked history and he really liked Greek mythology. And so when he was looking for a name for this complex that he'd identified, he went to that same source. He went back to Greek mythology. And of course, he found the perfect story. story of Edipus. If you are not familiar with it, in the story, Edipus, the character, the main character, is told by an oracle that he is destined to kill his father and to marry his mother. Now, this prophecy wasn't just given to Oedipus himself, but was delivered years earlier to his biological parents. And his biological parents were this very famous king and queen. And so when they were told that story when he
was born, they wanted to prevent it. So they ordered that the infant be killed. they ordered that their son, Oedipus, you know, be murdered. Instead, he wasn't murdered. He was abandoned on a mountainside and he was found and he was raised by another family completely unaware of his true origins. He later receives the prophecy, but he believes the people who he knows as his mother and father are his real mother and father. And so he tries to escape his fate by fleeing them, by avoiding them. But in his efforts to do that, he, as he is, he is, he tries to escape his fate. And so he, he tries to escape his fate by by avoiding them. But in his efforts to do that,
he, as he is fleeing, he encounters an old man at a crossroad, on a road. They have a heated argument. He kills him. That man is his father. He doesn't know that. He thinks his father is back in his hometown.
And he then travels to Thebes where he solves this riddle. And the result of him solving this riddle is that he gets to assume the throne and take the hand of the widowed queen. he marries her, not realizing that the widow queen is in fact his mother. And so the prophecy comes true. You know, when it's finally revealed, it's very sad. Edipus blinds himself, his mother slash wife, dies by suicide. So it's just very dramatic. It's this big Greek story. And Freud heard that story, and he was like, that, I'm going to steal that. That sounds great. But also he thought, well, there's a reason this story must be so popular. It must be so popular because a lot of people relate to it.
So he kind of saw our interest in a story like that as a projection of an unconscious internal desire. So that's where the name Oedipus complex came from. So to understand why Freud thought this particular conflict emerged in early childhood, we also need to look at his broader theory of psychosexual development. So Freud divided childhood development into a sequence of stages. During each stage, he believed the libido, which for him, libido was not all about sex. It was also about, you know, the psychic energy of life and the pleasure-seeking energy of the human spirit.
Sex was involved. Not, wasn't everything. Like when we think of libido today, we just think sexual desire. No, for him it meant life. It meant energy. He believed that in each stage, our libido became focused upon a particular bodily area or developmental conflict. So as we moved through childhood, we move through these stages. was the oral stage, which is associated with the mouth and feeding. There is the anal stage,
which is associated with bowel control, the phallic stage, the latency period, and finally, the genital stage, which Freud associated with more, like, mature sexuality. Now, the Oedipus complex was supposed to reach its peak during the phallic stage, which is around three to six years old. During this period, Freud believed children became especially interested in their bodies. They became very interested in, like, their anatomical features and how the sexes, differed in that way. And he kind of saw that as that they were, I don't know, he really read a lot into that in a way that we probably wouldn't today. For us, we kind of understand that children are curious because they are learning. Freud took that a whole step further and was like,
this curiosity must reflect a sexual desire within the family and this idea that children are, you know, it just got very, very strange. So in his mind, And he thought that as children, specifically boys, went through this period, that is when they experienced this conflict between, you know, wanting their mother, hating their father. And the only way for them to get through that conflict was to realize that they couldn't have their mother and therefore they should become like their father to find somebody like their mother later on in life. They begin to emulate their father.
They begin to copy him. this is called identification and it's how boys learn to be men, it's how they learn what's right in society. In practice, he was like, well, this is why, and this really explains why boys go through this period of really loving their mothers, being very much like mother-orientated to wanting to be like their fathers and suddenly taking an interest in the same activities as them, imitating them, wanting to dress like them, wanting to be around them all the time. That, to most of us would just be like, that's how children learn. They learn through socialization. They learn through experiences and modeling. Freud was like, well, no, it's because like they're sexually
attracted to their mother. And that's just where it gets very, very strange. But he did say by resolving the Oedipus complex, this is important for people, specifically boys, to learn social order to learn what is right, what is wrong, and to learn more about who they are and who they want to be. That is the outcome if it's resolved. Again, this is unconscious. So he says that even as boys get older, they never, they don't really realize that they ever had these desires. It just kind of is something that pushes them and shapes them and moves them forward. However, the desire never really goes away. So this is this interesting thing. Freud was like, well, in order to resolve and to become, like, in order to become more mature and to develop,
one should resolve this desire for the mother. But additionally, he also said, well, one actually never does, though. One never does. He basically believed that, you know, it just becomes more suppressed. And then it comes up later when a boy goes to choose his own life partner. And it's why he believed and why a lot of people will kind of have this, there's this weird myth in society that, you know, boys choose somebody who's just like their mom. And all of that comes back to the Oedipus complex.
Now, that's what happens if it's resolved, i.e. boys still unconsciously want someone like their mom, doesn't sound resolved to me. But if it was unresolved and if the boy never learned to give up this unconscious desire and never learned to identify with the father, what Freud believed happened was that they developed a fixation or they became emotionally and developmentally frozen at this point in their life. And what that meant was that even as they get older, a man or a boy who has not resolved this conflict will become very frustrated, will really have difficulties with authority, have difficulties with jealousy and possessiveness and romantic relationships. So it's an important developmental stage for boys to go through. That is the basic
summary and basic theory that came from Freud's brain. Does it have any evidence? This theory is quite an old one and our scientific standards and abilities and testing functions have improved. With that, have we ever been able to find support for this theory that Freud couldn't when he was alive? Let's talk about it after this short break. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you.
Caffeine details at McDonald's.ca. At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me.
I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B.
I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first. trip. I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. From best-selling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table.
It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right of place. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. The US Open is back. That's right. Two weeks of incredible, exciting tennis. Some outrageous overreactions from players and some hot takes from people who have, let's face it, no idea what they're talking about, but it's okay because I'm here for them and you. I'm Renee Stubbs, and on the Renee Stubbs tennis podcast, I'll be breaking down everything that happens after big matches, who's playing the best tennis,
who looks like they could possibly win this tournament, the surprise runs, the heartbreaking exits, and all the drama that only the US Open can deliver. Coco looking real good. Her serve looks so much smoother than it has in the past. I was really happy to see Eager back to what she looked like a couple of years ago when she was winning dominantly. Listen, I'm going to let Venus decide when she wants to retire.
I'm going to let the tournaments decide when they don't want to give her a wild card because she still puts bums in seats, she still sells, and people love to see her play. You always say on this show that this is the best predictor of who will do well at the O'S Open. If this is a preview, then we are in for a treat. Listen to the Renee Stubbs Tennis Podcasts on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get you podcasts. So if you are hearing this episode and everything I'm serving to you now and thinking actually, what the fuck are you talking about? and this is not what I expected when I clicked on this episode,
you are absolutely not alone. I think we sometimes hear a name like Freud, and he's so celebrated in psychology, and he's this huge figure, and that lends his theories a lot of legitimacy, and then when you look at these theories, you realize that they are quite odd, and actually that there might not be that much evidence,
they were just so outlandish, and of the time, that they've just seemingly carried on. I really want to remind us, Freud existed in a time before rigorous psychological experimentation. And now that we do use processes that involve random sampling, experimental conditions, control groups, ethics committees, that big one, now that we do use those theories, sorry, we do use those methods. We have put the Oedipus complex as a theory through those standards and we've attempted to test it in this rigorous manner. And there has been absolutely no established evidence and no clinical test that can demonstrate
that the Oedipus complex as a universal or even mildly supported theory exists. Nobody has been able to find wide scale evidence. However, here is what is actually. quite tricky and what people don't always talk about. Freud presented a lot of his ideas as unconscious processes. And he presented a lot of his ideas in a way that meant we cannot falsify them. We cannot prove that they do not occur. This was a very smart thing he did, whether he did it deliberately or not. But the way a lot of Freud's theories are set up is that they are very hard to prove wrong, even if we know they are not right. I mentioned this in the Freud episode,
but when you have a scientific theory, your scientific theory should ideally make predictions that allow researchers to actually test whether this thing exists or doesn't exist. But when you create a theory that says this is entirely unconscious, therefore if you don't find evidence for it, that proves it. And if you do find evidence for it, that proves it as well. It becomes nearly impossible to decisively conclude whether something is real or not. For example, Freud often treated and worked in the space of dreams and interpretations and projection and all these other things. And the thing was is that if a patient agreed with his interpretation, that would support his theory. but if a patient strongly rejected his interpretation, that could also be interpreted as evidence.
Then we put this in the kind of way of the Oedipus complex. If you go up to a bunch of people, you do a randomized, controlled study with a thousand people and you say, have you ever experienced any of these feelings towards your own mother that you can remember or acknowledge? If somebody says yes, I do, great, you get to count that as evidence. If somebody says absolutely not, that is so weird, great, you also get to count that as evidence. The reason being, because the Oedipus complex is treated as this unconscious, suppressed, unresolved desire.
And so denying it is just as much evidence of its existence as a, agreeing with it and saying that I've experienced that. So when almost every possible outcome can be interpreted as support for a theory, that theory, just by its basis, is a great one in terms of like, like if you're somebody who never wants to be proven wrong, like Freud. But a terrible one when it comes to actually trying to identify a truth about humanity and a truth about society. Another huge issue with this theory, beyond that, and it's probably something you've been like trying to screaming at me to mention this whole time, I promise you I was getting to it, is the fact that it doesn't acknowledge that homosexuality exists. It doesn't have an explanation
for people who have single parents. It doesn't have an explanation for people who have divorced parents. It doesn't have an explanation for people who are raised in communal societies, people who are transgender, people who are non-binary, people who have same-sex parents. And the biggest blaring omission, it really doesn't mention girls. the Oedipus complex seems to be entirely about boys. The homosexuality thing, I will say, is, like, I think the biggest problem. Like, it just doesn't make any sense, you know, all of those things. I'm like, oh, well, the homosexuality thing.
But then also the single-parent thing, but then also, like, the divorce parent thing, like, he just didn't have explanations for those things. But when it came to women and all young girls and how they fit into the theory, it gets a whole lot weirder. I know you're probably like, that's impossible. I've just heard you go on and on about this crazy thing. No, it gets a lot weirder. So he proposed that girls initially have a close attachment to their mother,
which is most children, but during the phallic stage, they supposedly become aware that they do not have a penis. I know, I told you, it was going to get weird. Freud claimed that when women realize, that they go, I don't have a penis. My dad does. My mother doesn't. They get all confused. And they interpret this as a deficiency. And they blame their mother for the fact that they don't have a penis. And they redirect their attention towards their father because they possess something that
that she lacks, i.e. all young girls secretly want a penis. And this creates a concept known as penis envy. That means they hate their mother and they admire their father. Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy. Eventually, like, Freud says that, you know, the girl comes back. She begins to realize she can never get a penis. She identifies with her mother. And she seeks, in his words, symbolic substitutes for the penis, including in Freud's account, the desire to have a baby. and the desire to have a boy. Yeah, all women secretly, all women secretly have penis envy,
and they secretly want to have children to fill that void, specifically boy children. If you've ever, the idea of a boy mom, like this idea of like, oh, I'm a boy mom and like this whole thing online about boy moms,
Freud would have a field day with that. That actually provides a lot of evidence for his theory, which is crazy. like that's crazy that, yeah, women on TikTok and like on Instagram being like, I love my, I'm like, I love being a boy mom and like, oh my God, I love my son more than I've ever loved any man. And I don't know what I'm going to do when he like, he loves another woman. I might just kill her, like all those crazy things.
He's literally like, not proving, but providing evidence for this crazy whack job theory that Freud had about women. There is another term, though, that we use sometimes that describes this. It's called the Electra Complex. This is actually labelled by Carl Jung, who was Freud's predecessor. But Freud didn't want a separate term for what happened to women in this period. He liked Oedipus Complex. He just kind of thought that women, like, it was kind of an afterthought for him.
So these ideas are naturally crazy. Let's just call it as we see it. And they were naturally challenged at the time within the psychoanalytic, like psychoanalytic community, specifically by a woman called Karen Horny. She was a German psychoanalyst operating at the same time as Freud. And she basically heard this theory and was like, that is insane. Do you know women? Do you speak to women who aren't your patients or like your daughter? Like that's, this is, you've interpreted this whole thing through a male-centered lens, one that is probably inaccurate as well. She suggested that rather than perceiving women, rather than women perceiving their
own bodies as defective as a result of some apparent. an envy for men, it's not envy that they are experiencing towards the penis. Women are experiencing envy around the access to social freedom and independence and authority and power that was available to men at the time. To her, it was just insane to say that all women secretly wanted a penis because they were sexually jealous and attracted to their father. She basically said, no, this is again, all part of socialization. And it's all part of girls and boys learning at a critical age around six or seven, they start to really realize what is my role in society because of my gender. What is expected of me? What is and isn't correct in the eyes of society?
And how do I adjust that with my own sense of self? That possessiveness as well of parents that Freud saw as indication of sexual desire, unconscious sexual attraction, it's also just really normal when you're a kid. Do you know what I mean? Like, it's really normal when you're a child to maybe favor one parent or to maybe identify more with one parent based on your gender. And it's really normal for children to try and make sense of relationships through the relationship that their parents have and say, oh, I want to marry somebody like mommy because, well, they've only probably been this close to one example of a relationship their whole lives. It's really quite normal for children to feel like they want more attention from their
mother or from their father, whoever is the primary caregiver. and to see the other parent as competition because children are greedy and children are 100% reliant on their caregiver. So anything that feels like that's going to take them away from that, obviously they're going to react accordingly. So these days the theory is seen as a bit of a joke and seen as a little bit funny, right? It's like taking, it's like somebody being like, well, how are apples made? in coming up with this like elaborate idea of like somebody sewing an apple to a tree.
Like we know the children go through these things. Is it because of this weird whack-dob idea that they are somehow unconsciously desiring their parents? Probably not. And it was a real big reason why at the time Freud got into a lot of fights and a lot of professional arguments with his colleagues, including his predecessor to Carl Jung, who basically stopped talking to him because he was like, you need to chill out. Your theories are a little bit perverted. And also, what?
Like, also, why? You know, like, they just were a bit like, you need to just maybe go for a walk and actually maybe speak to women a bit more that aren't just your patients and also maybe not make everything about sex. So with that being said, does this theory have any lasting value?
As a literal universal theory of childhood development, no, it does not. have any value because it excludes a whole lot of the diversity that exists in real families in our society today and it just actually can't explain it. It can only explain a very, very narrow, very narrow section of society in a way that is also probably not true. Besides that, the theory has an enormous historical and cultural impact. I think because of how shocking it is, you know, this whole idea is really memorable. It challenges deeply held assumptions about innocence, about family bonds, about morality, about sex.
And I think the shock factor behind this theory is what makes it and continues to keep it present in popular culture and in academic debates to this day. If we were going to give Freud any of his flowers, and if there was anything good to take from this, I will say he did acknowledge that humans and children are complex. And he did acknowledge that children can have conflicting ideas, or complex ideas, which at the time wasn't that widely held, right? He really did, he saw people as acting irrationally, he saw people as acting imperfectly, and he kind of saw the fact that children do start to have their own personalities and desires in a way that clinicians
probably weren't really talking about that widely at the time. So these days, we've cherry-picked, we've refined, we've developed the idea, and we've just created a bit more of a robust theory. We've come a long way since like 100 years ago where this was like the best thing we could come up with. Nowadays we understand that children go through these different developmental periods. They naturally become more curious about themselves, including their body, including their anatomy. And whilst that is happening, they also become more aware of the social dynamics surrounding them. And so whilst these things may look like they're happening at the same time, time or look like they're causing one another. That is not the case. It is just the pathway
that people take. Multiple things are happening in the developmental life of a child at the same time. That is all I have for you today. If you had no idea what this was about, I'm, I feel like I need to apologize. I feel like you've come into this being like, oh my God, yeah, I'm just going to listen to this at the gym, just going to listen to this in the car with my parents or my friends. And suddenly you're like, oh my God, why does she keep saying sex, an unconscious desire, and penis and envy, penis envy. So I'm sorry, I still hope you learned something from this episode. I think it's a really good thing to know.
And once you start understanding this, you can kind of catch certain jokes that you see in pop culture, you start being able to apply it to like funny things that you see. So, yes, I hope you learnt. I hope you were shocked, but not unhappy with the, with the, contents of this episode. I want to thank our research would Libby for helping us with this episode today. If you did not know already, you can watch all of our episodes on Netflix. Not this episode. I don't think it would have gotten past their standards. I don't think they would have let me do an episode on this, but all of our non-bonous episodes of which there are a lot are now on Netflix.
Go give it a look. Go give it a watch. You can also follow us on Instagram, substack. Everything you need to know will be in the description, including an entire. entire playlist of every single one of our bonus episodes, have a look down there, you'll find it, and you can listen to some of our other ones. I promise they're a lot less raunchy than this. But thank you for listening all the way to the end. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus, or this random dude is offering.
me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture, with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed.
Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So, like, by Asia 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is Therapy for Black Girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening inside your kid's brain, the group chat, and their friendships, and what you can do about it. Your child is not doing this on purpose. That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health.
and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to decoding women's help with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.